how many filmmakers do you know who make
a living making movies so I've had
several clients who have gone on to you
know great careers in making films
um I sold Chaka King's first film
newlyweeds who went on to Judas in the
Messiah one of Mike Flanagan's early
films Absentia now
um made this the the um The Shining
um
sequel
um and lots of other great horror films
and and series for Netflix
um I I co-produced and helped sell
several films with Ron Bergman who's a
producer he's now partnered with Ryan
Johnson and they did um
Star Wars 8 and
um Looper and several other and knives
out and several other great films
um so I have a handful of clients that
have gone on to to have you know great
Hollywood careers
um I have a few clients as well that
still make movies they're still trying
to make that one that graduates to the
studio level but still making indie
films
um
some
some still very Indie some kind of in
the quasi-hollywood Indie world of
catching talent and having sales agents
you know pre-sell their move movies
there's lots of those movies that kind
of out there that don't bubble up but
still kind of make money in strange ways
um
and um
and then there's a lot of people that
are one and done
um just because it was so such a big
effort to get that first one out there
and
um they just never could get quite back
to making number two
um that's partly because it's just hard
to make a film that makes money and um
and I think it's it's easier when you're
young I like to bootstrap it and do it
for nothing and get all call in all your
favors but it's hard to call in the
favors twice
um so yeah it's definitely a mix
sure and if you have debt from the movie
yeah
um
that's difficult yeah
yeah so and most people I know were I
think most films I rep
were mostly equity
most of them tend to be have found an
equity investor to make the film as
opposed to renting their credit cards so
it's not debt per se and that they have
to pay it back they just have
disgruntled
investors maybe but um
or not overly happy but um
but um
yeah I think
it's uh yeah it's just it's just not
it's not easy to make a movie and it's
um
I'd say
you know me I don't know what the
percentages are but I'd say probably 70
80 percent you know don't go on to make
a second film at least
well that's that's high that's
unfortunate but
yeah well there's just a lot of stuff
that I mean we've got a lot of movies
out there and it's not that like they
don't go on to do great things other
ways right like it's you know
um same I've definitely had clients like
like well I made this film but I'm never
doing it again
like they that's the way they feel after
after making for one like it's just it
was a lot to to get that one off the
ground whatever that felt like to them
so
yeah it's not always a sad story it's
sometimes just what they choose they
just choose A New Path right they got it
out of their system yeah yeah exactly
what's the budget range of the movies
you typically work with
yeah the range is micro to like almost
nothing to
several million
three four million
I'm maybe a couple times I've had seven
million dollar films but pretty rare
how does a half million dollar movie
make its money back
so
um there are lots of potential ways to
make it back but
um
for a half million dollar movie
you most likely need to
get it into a major Festival
and have someone
pay you that and more back up front
because if you most half million dollar
films don't make their money back
so
that's you know
it's just half a million dollars it you
know implies no cast really right
um
that I mean when I say no Castle I mean
there are people in the movie but
there's no names in the movie per se
that help sell it
and that's you're going up against a lot
of independent films out there that have
names that were made at two million
dollars and even those movies don't get
sometimes don't get a half million
dollars for their U.S sale
so you're really up against it it's
really it's tough
but I have had plenty of half million
dollar movies that made
you know a hundred thousand in the
transactional VOD world the distributor
managed to sell
to uh
cable entity for a couple hundred
thousand and then it made more money on
avod to get to that half million dollar
number
um and I'm sorry avod sorry advertising
video on demand and that's where the ads
play that's where the ads is okay great
sorry um
are there certain films that are
domestically made but they are hits
overseas but they're not here
it's pretty rare these days
um the one of the reasons I decided to
get into domestic sales as a producer
rep as opposed to International sales
was I saw it going down
um 15 years ago
um
um you know there was a day when
International sales was Major and talk
about we're talking about true Indies
here okay not there's still a market
overseas for films with names in
quasi-independent films made by
Hollywood production companies we talk
about true indie films
um there's barely a market now overseas
and that's partly because at one point
we we used to be able to sell almost
anything overseas 25 years ago
the this is you know there were cable
channels around the world and
um video stores around the world that
needed content
and U.S producers were the only ones
that could make them at a price
and we were the only ones really doing
it in mass and so we were flooding the
world with our content
so fast forward past you know um
the writer strike creates the reality
television and the cost of production
all comes down
and countries around the world start
making their own content for their own
communities
there's just not there's just no Demand
anymore at all for True Independent
films
um
there's still a pretty good
I almost say good but there's still a
business for films in the three million
dollars and up range
that are made you know in not with that
with the studio but independently in
Hollywood with a name attached to it
where they can make sales around the
world that come up to 50 to 70 percent
of a budget
but that doesn't exist for True
Independence
even if they get someone and they pay
them a day rate maybe they weren't
they're not an a-lister but they're
recognizable yeah these days you it's
like you to me for for sales purposes
it's really A-list or nothing
um I think when you're when you're if
you're gonna
if you're casting for name value and
it's that level you should also be
making you should probably really
uh be getting them because they're
really great for the role
um much more important than what their
name value is and you're hoping that the
combination of them being
um great for the role
and a little bit of name value catapults
it into another sphere then the you
everything else out there
um
but yeah I see a lot of films that cast
B level talent I should say not level
but you know value Talent
um
for that purpose and it just doesn't
didn't make a difference
right I'm just thinking of overseas as
well so it sounds like maybe 15 16 20
years ago yeah we could do that easily
back then there was a you know it was a
day when you could just tell an
international distributor oh I've got so
and so in it and and they just believed
you right and that they didn't even know
that the person had value
or not
and that's how you know that's how
Westworld it was at one point you know
um
or Wild
um but they're all much more
sophisticated now
um they'll know exactly what they need
and what their audiences want and who's
worth what and so it's it's really kind
of
you know again there's
again going back to those three million
dollar level films where you know there
are some actors that have kind of popped
up in value because they were in big
Studio films and so there's a certain
recognizability there's certain name
value that's still there but they're not
getting
you know they're not leading roles in in
big Studio movies they still are trying
out for them maybe they're trying to be
the next Marvel guy or whatever but
they're not getting it but they still
have some value so for a few years
they'll be castable in that kind of
budget range
and usually in Thrillers or horror films
or you know elevated horror you know
something very commercial
action as well
um
but um
but it's uh
but that list is pretty it's a pretty
small list and it changes
and it's subjective too I find that like
just because one sales company has an
affinity
for one level one actor
with a little bit of name value they
might have that Affinity because they
had a film last year that they sold with
him that did well
but the sales agent over here doesn't
have that experience
and doesn't didn't hasn't made a film
with that guy so they don't have this
put the same value on him that that
other company does
so it's not like a you know a where like
you can't rely on IMDb scores
um for Value they really you know
sometimes they correlate but most of the
time they don't because people pop up
and down on that list
um pretty wildly now
with faith-based films is the only place
to sell them is to certain Networks
yeah I'm not that conversant and
faith-based stuff I've never sold a
faith-based film
um from what I understand
um you know there's a mega church that
kind of
um there's one or two of them that have
done you know quite a good job in the
past of
of of creating these faith-based films
for their
um their audiences and and Screen those
films for the churches as a way to
create a Groundswell for selling off the
ancillary rights later
um
and um
and and I think that there's
um their faith-based production
companies that have kind of figured out
the formula and the name value that they
need and can kind of and know how to do
that
um
but if someone came to me with a face
faith-based film I'd say hey you know
um if it if it also works for a secular
audience I know where to go with it but
if it's purely faith-based and very or
very overtly faith-based there's better
there's there's routes that I don't
really know that much about